ed miliband setting his promises in
stone literally this eight-foot
limestone slab detailing Labour's
election pledges will be erected in the
number ten garden if he wins the
election initially most people thought
it was a joke then the parody started
comparing it to a gravestone or the
tablet containing the Ten Commandments
with just four days until the general
election ed miliband spoke exclusively
to Sky News you haven't proven that you
can be the next prime minister the polls
are pretty much the same now as they
were when you first started campaigning
well I don't quite see it that way look
I think that this campaign has been an
opportunity certainly for me to set out
what I believe how we change this
country to work for working people it's
a big choice for people so why hasn't
that been a reflective I think also
people are making up their minds look
you know this is an election which is
gonna be an incredibly tight election
he's gonna come down to the wire if you
lose will it be your fault well I'm
proud of the campaign that we've run and
I'm proud of the leadership that I also
had the country's got choice I've never
been somebody who says that it's all
about image I think it's about substance
and the way we change things Hades
matter to is of course it matters of
course it matters but it's not simply an
image contest it's a contest about ideas
ideas to make this country work for
working people again it's a real issue
here is that people just don't trust
labor on the economy do they are you
just too left-wing to be Prime Minister
that's not the way I see it anyone who
wants to make a credible government has
got to have a plan B why don't you be
straight with people don't take the
people for fools what is your plan B I'm
very very straight with people which is
that I will seek to play a labor program
before the House of Commons I want a
majority labour government I want to put
in place a plan to put working people
first again all those undecided voters
some of them we saw today but even a
cider daters are worried about who you
might do a deal with what about the lib
dems would you brought our coalition SMP
what about Anna tempting as it is to be
I'm really not getting into that I've
ruled out version no but you know I
don't really care what they throw at me
I care about what will be thrown at the
British people over the next five years
of David Cameron gets back into power
and you know i'm a pretty resilient guy
and I think I've shown that less than a
hundred hours to go in this election I
need you frankly ed Miliband needs them
to do a lot here in Dudley and across
the country the polls show that labor is
unlikely to win a majority on Thursday
he won't admit it but Ed Miliband will
be thinking hard about plan B safety
rich Sky News Dudley